- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
Give me one sec.
- How you doing today?
- [Gary] I'm doing really well.
How was your weekend?
- It was good.
How was yours?
- [Gary] Good, man, family.
It was hot as shit.
- I know.
- [Gary] We had a baseball,
we had a birthday party
for my little guy,--
- Right.
- [Gary] and it was fucking bad.
- Yeah, it was rough to
be outside for a long time.
Do you guys have a pool
you go in or something?
- [Gary] We do but my wife
decided it wasn't a pool party
which I don't know.
Wasn't necessarily the smartest
move of her career
but it was fucking hot.
- Yeah.
It was like 90 with
the humidity and stuff.
- [Gary] What'd you do?
- I went to Splish Splash.
I don't know if you ever been.
It's like a water
park on Long Island.
- [Gary] Dude, do you know
what's so funny about that?
This is not a joke.
I think I like water parks
more than anything on Earth.
- Oh really?
- [Gary] Like Wet 'n Wild--
- Yeah.
- [Gary] is like my
favorite place on Earth.
- Really? Have you ever
been to Splish Splash?
- [Gary] No. Where is it?
- It's Long Island, Riverhead.
- [Gary] How far is
that from the Hamptons?
Like an hour?
- Not even.
- [Gary] Splish Splash?
- Splish Splash.
- [Gary] I'm gonna
take my kids there.
- Yeah, it's probably,
it's supposed to be
one of the better water parks--
- [Gary] Places, you enjoyed it?
- Yeah. I've been there before.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- Yeah.
I grew up on Long Island so.
- [Gary] So tell
me about yourself?
What are you doing here?
- Bud Light account--
- [Gary] Yep.
- executive, really enjoying it.
I'm excited about that
new transfer and stuff.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Just to keep
learning and growing.
Taking on more.
- [Gary] Good.
How'd you get here?
- I worked at a digital
agency on Long Island.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- And I actually worked
with someone you might know,
Jacob Arlich.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Yeah, he was my boss.
We're actually good
friends but I worked there.
I knew about you.
I reached out LinkedIn and--
- [Gary] Away you went.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Good for you, brother.
How long you been here?
- Four months.
- [Gary] Four months.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And how's it going?
- I like it. I love it.
- [Gary] Good,
how's the culture?
- Yeah, good.
- [Gary] Good.
- Steve's good, my team's great.
We all support each
other in everything.
- [Gary] Who's been
bringing you value?
- Um, (censored).
- [Gary] Yeah, he's the best.
- Yeah, he does a lot.
- [Gary] He's a good dude.
- Yeah, he is. He's a nice
guy but everyone on
the team is super
supportive and good.
- [Gary] Love it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And so, tell me a
little bit more about yourself.
Long Island.
- Yeah, Long Island.
- [Gary] What are you into?
- Horseback ride.
- [Gary] No. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Back to
back horseback riding.
Last person too.
- Oh, really?
- [Gary] Yeah.
Good for you, man.
- Yeah, I volunteer at a place.
I'm into fitness.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Exercising.
- [Gary] Good shape.
- Reading. Just trying to
better myself here.
- [Gary] Awesome, man.
Good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Siblings?
- No.
- [Gary] Solo.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Love it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] Very cool.
Anything I can answer for you?
- No, I mean, what do you think
I could do to bring value to my
team more as
an account executive
that's shifting
into this new role?
- [Gary] I have a
really good answer.
Asking questions and then
listening to the answers.
- [Matt] Okay.
- I think a lot of
people are scared to ask.
- [Matt] Mhmmm.
- Like it's scary to ask [censored]
what may seem like something you
think he thinks you should know.
- [Matt] Mhmmm.
- That's the biggest
thing that holds people back.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Deploying enough
humility to ask the question,
is the game.
It's the, I'm actually giving
you a piece of advice that
I wish I took
when I was younger.
I had too much pride
in thinking I knew,--
- [Matt] Mhmmm.
- Too many people
here are just yes-ing.
Like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, got it. I know, right?
The number one thing you can do
by bringing value is actually
closing the gap on
anything you don't know and
you do that by asking.
You know?
- [Matt] Mhmmm.
- And I would just
form more relationships.
I think one of the biggest
mistakes youngsters are making
here is we have such a nice
culture so you go and you homey
up with [censored]
and it's super cozy
but there's all
these other people.
Like where's your relationship,
you should ask
Joe Catrone for 15 minutes.
- [Matt] Mhmmm. Yeah.
- Seems scary but it's not.
Not here. Not in a
world where I do it. Got it?
- [Matt] So take
advantage of that.
- Do it. It seems weird
or on the creative side
hitting up Todd Bradley.
Being like, "Hey, can I grab 10
minutes with you and just,"
it seems tough but it's
the number one fucking game.
- Cool.
- [Gary] And if you feel like in
a couple months you're still not
doing it and you
think about this.
You're on the
train, you're like,
"Fuck, Gary said
for me to do that.
"I haven't done it."
If you need me to help, I will.
And I've done
that a couple times.
Some people have just been like
too introverted or didn't think
it was appropriate.
I'll do it for you.
I'll send emails to
(mumbles) I'll be like,
"Hey, chill with
Matty for 15 minutes."
- Cool. Yeah.
- [Gary] Alright?
- Definitely reach out.
- [Gary] Alright.
- What can I do
for you with this?
- [Gary] I'm good for now, man.
I'm comfortable
with asking for stuff.
I like giving more but you know,
but being a part of the culture,
bringing people value.
- Cool.
- [Gary] Being a good dude.
Being patient
humble but confident,
work hard, those
are good traits.
- Awesome.
Thank you.
Was a pleasure to meet you.
- [Gary] Real pleasure, man.
I wish you well.
- [Matt] Thank you.
- [Gary] Take care, man.
- [Matt] Tell me how
you like Splish Splash.
- [Gary] I will.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm actually gonna do it.
I'm literally texting
my wife right now.